I honestly I have not we have not had an
easier game than our two competitive
games every other games I don't know why
Robbie sweetie [ __ ] on then at least
a try hard [ __ ] thanks grenade by me
through a rain to the ground
oh no Craig wants to join the party you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
oh damn it Crowley is minus one mean you
want to get off are you guys yes
hey crank let's go yeah let's see hey
what's up Steve what are you guys doing
great I'm actually really angry right
now because I'll play another one of
Steve bling guns do you have
well what are you using what do you do
yeah vote do you have a bike on you know
I know Craig sucks
dude Craig don't have a mic on yeah yeah
you don't I don't have any gun dude so
us was bad don't give me the whole
review but spoilers but was it bad yeah
I did I didn't like it I really didn't
like it
like I here's here's my poor woman it's
not beautiful it's shot beauty yeah
great everything great yeah so I I get
what they tried to do but there's so
many [ __ ] there's so many plot holes
in it like what do you mean by it what I
mean by it what I mean by it is like you
twist whatever at the end you're like oh
yeah that's a pretty crazy cool twist
but then you're thinking of the movie it
absolutely don't tell me about the twist
now this twist I'm not no no I'm not
telling you about like twist but like
oh my god twisting the throttle there's
there's so much there's so many
unanswered questions there's just so
many unanswered questions like amazing
the trailer no there's there's amazing
parts about it but like one of those
movies where you're like you want you're
okay there's more to this like we're
gonna find out yeah
then when you have towards the end and
you like the [ __ ] starts unraveling as
to what happened you're still lay up
that's that's still not [ __ ]
believable though this like it's still
[ __ ] ridiculous like I just have a
general question yeah there's no
spoilers in my question is it Sparta as
part of the spoiler but it's [ __ ]
random to now I'm like it's because it's
it's oh go just go see it
what what Griffin saw I gave Craig a
Ouija board today and he's like breaking
it open you believe this [ __ ] can you
well you should vlogging blogging okay I
don't even know how to use the
controllers here what kind of gun is
this
he's a narrative this is new [ __ ] I
don't know I don't even know how to use
these
guns it's been so what Zenith okay yeah
uncle my father cuz I'm old school like
that a sign of energy shotgun and a
light machine gun energy shotgun
do you have an energy shotgun Craig
Zenith ears please God seniors have your
eyes without work is that good
okay he's got since up the path dude
that's an old-ass rocket launcher bro
sins works on this [ __ ] yeah Steve just
remember that when you finish playing on
his account delete the highest light of
that we've been trying to big man 360
for Viton you know what I like pulse
rifles so what's this we doin our
capture the flag
yes that's all we want to hear no just
wait to you just wait till you get your
ass whipped by your well as you can see
we're double that but if you buy these
the season pass you get four bounties
and when you buy oh my god pasty it
immediately jumps you the sixth
immediately Sam is calling me 6:40 no
you're not that far behind if you spent
$30 okay just forsaken just forsaken
you've missed okay now Mike is gonna be
like negative something you're Pauly you
I'm just gonna hide behind picket you
and shoot with this yeah is that a plan
yeah I think yeah I think you're
probably gonna improve phrase KTU and if
you haven't played for a year I don't
know how to use it Titan I'm just
letting you know ma I like hunters gonna
be difficult this is gonna be bad he
would play each other warlock I mean I'm
a hunter oh my god a warlock hunter
hunter yeah no the chat says they need a
toge in the blind sequel current a Steve
totin the blind sequel whoa that's a
they said please tell Steve I need a
toad in the blind sequel oh my Toton the
elf the blind al yeah [ __ ] is craig
wearing it sight of those like football
pants for like five years and then he
gets mad
they nerves land they nerve slang yeah
they didn't even perfect hey I know dude
I they did something
yes no like Craig has this $800
controller it has like I don't even know
if this is a normal controller there's
buttons well we have exact same one oh
yeah okay Jeff says they want another
story they say that it helps them fall
asleep it's good for TV it's good okay
dude so well who's the world my father
just follow hope if you follow coke you
will win oh [ __ ] this is bad dude
and we're playing capture the flag
vertigo dude I don't even know how to
walk where there's somebody behind me
dude
I'm shooting you I'm shooting you I'm
sorry so sorry don't worry there's no
team damage
on be right now I killed someone when I
punched them in the face
nice my Steve but I still don't on a
shoot like I'm right sure they're
vertical damn play my [ __ ] dad Christ
back
oh my god like it's oh no don't do
that's me thank you
Thank You Zack Turley they're getting a
they're getting a they're getting a wall
my [ __ ] slack we get B can we get B for
that [ __ ] [ __ ] misfit melts
I don't think I shot anyone I'm shooting
up to the ceiling this guy got me the
rocket launcher I'm so sorry
I think I'm ruining you guys I'm not
ruining anything you've been here's a
good idea now this is a very bad idea
quick I don't know how to play this game
anymore this is so embarrassing
creig help me out here how what do I do
this guy's really just pop the sound
shield well you should mean it I can't
kill them I avenged Kofi ye we both
threw all of our needs enemy or it's
scary I don't know what I'm doing bro I
don't know how to play this game it's
[ __ ] up dude you have a shotgun Craig
has a shotgun it's press y Steve it's
then another kind or some [ __ ] whatever
that's called Zenith
all right don't laugh that's nice
what jumping around like a goddamn funny
Craig dude I don't even know how to read
the map I don't know how to shoot out oh
okay who's that who's that
oh dude spectral blade is so broken she
should be dead a spectrum it's still
working
running
sellers Steve hasn't played for a year
in yeah here
oh my god I'm so sorry guys this is a
horrible idea
yeah
I didn't know I had a big wall I thought
I had the little tiny reload wall
oh that's hammers hammers I'm gon see ya
you turn on my tail yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's it now I think they're gone so
I'm gonna go back and kill him now
[ __ ] Bose [ __ ] melts
man what [ __ ] what are you what are you
laughing at dude support can you guys
stop being negative
mr. panic Vista panic did I love falling
right here you know what that would be a
lot bro
what do you laugh again unfortunately I
don't know I am swear to god how did he
survive the first time they walked away
like then negative HP I know I don't
know I don't think I've got a clear shot
on anyone
that's make me blood red man
okay dude nice try
last word keep playing Steve nah deep
Steve building a lady I forgot about
grenades you can throw grenades yeah god
Steve did you get in an accident or
something
come on he played destiny was not but
the thing is I haven't played it so long
it's a majesty patronize me dude don't
[ __ ] patronize me right now this no
you're perfect Steve read me your
picture it's probably the worst person
to be next to Steve when he's getting
back into the game is okay dude what
kind of that's like I'm playing on a
movie theater screen dude this is oh
yeah and you're playing on Craig's TV
that's the worst
what are you laughing at I punched it
what are you laughing at I punched it
why do you keep looking at me
frickin horrible idea
I know it's a it's a hunter come back
and hit me what you oh hey Steve watch
out the end of the maps over there I
know I I'm just laughing with you Steve
you were played together but Craig's
just laughing at me
Craig's not experiencing it so he can't
partake Oh dick yeah dude I it's almost
like he's getting away with [ __ ] that
shouldn't happen in this [ __ ] game
that's he's gone away from me twice with
0 HP
telling he's cheating they're coming
back I know we got to get any or
something come on it always was it were
we ahead yeah but or damn good wait what
are you saying I'm trying to chew
[ __ ] you Mac mall you [ __ ] are
garbage [ __ ] get his own get get a
someone right now how come I can't get
good names
yeah well I'm defending you Steve what
are you laughing at Craig they're
panicking
I got him did you want it get it you get
it did you get it you get it you get it
all I can see it's I'm the reason why
we're losing I'm so sorry guys no you're
not dude look at my Katie look at this
baby
look at my Katie just look at my KDS oh
my god [ __ ] you back mom god this is
like the old times huh
sorry
he's got a phone earlier real got a
power-play baby we gotta power play
let's win this let's go oh oh we won
baby for Steve what's up around this
morning Steve Epstein believe we need
you again we go Steve
wait wait till you see my KD it's not
that bad not that bad great great if you
were like point zero five or something
at least look at the other team zero
point two three
that's terrible you're you are almost
positive Steve and you got ten kills you
double your KD and you know dude I'm
sweating will you switch uh-huh
why do I have this helmet on can you
give me a better helmet cries hey but
I'll tell you what good helmet maker
breaks yeah okay what's a good chest
piece for a Titan no no level doesn't
matter that level doesn't matter it
oh my the Maxwells 350 max light levels
350 so if he has anything above that
he's cheating so just get rid of it now
is actually really good good well don't
say I'm so sorry Steve you bring you in
at night to the podcast
okay which is are you mad Craig's upset
at me Craig's looking away you kids
better than him laughing at you let's
just hear me out Craig gets like a point
five okay so my hunter role you know
like cuz I could disappear when I do my
role show me your body that was your
just hey the chat says to keep do sir
see Twitter show and keep the vlogs
coming and they said you're
inspirational
alright thank you I appreciate that guys
appreciate that okay so where you guys
gonna be a let's talk it out I'm gonna
see Raymond I'm gonna I'm gonna
see this is more like it I didn't know
how to aim with it see this is more like
it
nice team shooting nice team shooting
good job dude get [ __ ] wrecked and
it's either gonna see they're getting
tea they're gonna see just keep just
keep the rotation just go take me now
just keep running to the circle they
have one guy defending this place - it's
probably the same guy what are you
laughing at
[Laughter]
yes I did
now pick it up and go shoot someone okay
see now it's all coming back see how
that happens see how yes you just need a
good support structure and now you're
killing it
now I'm not killing it budget well
they're all over here see
wait hiding dude dude he's one shot
nice look at that Steve just avenged me
yeah it was a little minor it is good
it's good they're all tied up see you
kept trying to go to the tunnel careful
see I know this map I know how they
think they like going in the tunnels
hiding with their shotguns I would all
do doubts okay guys oh I'm getting shot
from somewhere I'll water it's all
behind us I guess yeah did you somehow
on the matter yeah like way of get shot
from like the sky way would you
you're not the devil are you gonna see
the movie us with cranks key discovered
this hasn't me oh no he doesn't like the
movie great dude we're gonna uh oh I
just still want to watch it's a worse
thing once though Eric we yeah okay
that's all I wanted it about that's all
I wanted there's still good [ __ ] about
it yeah no I'd love just getting [ __ ]
shield bashed it's fun don't you I also
enjoyed it art snaps is going to do best
yep right just got [ __ ] murder you
I'm getting murdered and just the
dumbest [ __ ] right now
the [ __ ] is happening
look this guy doing what's this guy
doing hey [ __ ] you doing it Brody what's
you up to you bro
if we win Steve can you secret team
coca-cola song yo yeah it's not team
coca-cola right now I'll tell you that
you [ __ ] get my ass boy it's always
it's always team coca-cola what are you
talking I know right I'm just gonna hold
B cuz it seems like we just have this
help then we're gonna be fine except for
the whole point that we're losing right
now Oh
oh all right we take si back I'm gonna
hold be we're gonna be fine
we're losing huh pretty bad no we're not
no not pretty bad for a pretty close
storm pants though watch out oh dude
first time I've seen a session with
blades on our team that's crazy
let's be good I can't wait right
actually I just got choked
don't do that don't rattle the cage
oh I just got oh my god [ __ ] chew on
one just two guys up there oh that was
it I don't know we can get a power plate
right now who's in two places nice nice
nice
alright go to Z go see go see Mike I
cleared see yeah yeah
I got heavy
oh my god he was in one shot that's so
annoying but I'm lucky what are you
laughing at Craig No
that's all right that's that way okay
dude that makes no sense he's not on the
map you're bad
I'm dead though
I swear it's like he jumps so high off
the map I can't see him anymore until he
falls back into my atmosphere I didn't
say that Shaq said
I'm really getting tethered by myself
that's [ __ ] fantastic
I'm very good target I can't
this is [ __ ] unreal I know what
you're doing you see my butt time to
swear to these guys
nope that's heavy
a bean cave I'm gonna murder you just
saying no I don't feel bad about it
either okay you're dead just like I
predicted so are you
well that's a [ __ ] nuke was that uh
total rc2 guys near a sorry two guys
near at
we got a special blades coming
I'm last place again all that feels
great all right all right the sneeze set
throw me off I'm dead because of it
Oh God oh that one hurt my chest you man
got a good neck cramp
this is horrible
you go poke nice on me
damn I'm over here I'm jumping on him
right now wow I'm getting killed by Skip
needs nice
wait whatever I took a chance it did not
work out Sentinel zoom that no shield
got left side but they getting like a
million [ __ ] supers man this is
[ __ ] crazy
he's [ __ ] I'm so sorry Craig
uprooting again I apologize
Wow
dammit not outraged whatever
and my left foots cramping so bad dude
Jesus crying I'm getting cramps Jesus
you still gonna have five man zone see
capture oh right here apparently
what
yeah baby whoo nice good job guys
I don't know I'm gonna sit down hell
yeah
you're not gonna say goodbye Steve of
the chat oh my god dude I just I don't
even know how to shoot any did Steve you
think great look you weren't positive
nobody went positive oh I did go
positive
hey guys I gotta call it a night here
guys
hey Steve pleasure pleasure playing with
you though yeah you too brother and coke
we'll work on dude a tier two and [ __ ]
like that tomorrow yeah we'll do that
later
you Denko yeah dude um it's [ __ ]
forth right here yeah it was a pleasure
man I've missed you guys always see you
next month Steve I'll be coming yeah
yeah yeah I'm coming next month
yeah so yeah dude
it could get you let's just um let's
just go into um I just want to practice
one more can we could just do one yes
sure okay
they can't grab me one more give me give
me a purple one don't matter yeah
Arthur man I am so out of date with this
I don't know what guns to use I don't
know how to use the suit you're doing
great
oh here I'm gonna leave the fire team
and I'm gonna send you an invite okay
I wrong thing wrong thing wait a minute
you these are pretty good right these
Swedish fishes
[Music]
and you got any no I'm good okay
not good I drink water
oh yeah I'm fine I like a water Hazen
invite Steve go do this just like the
old days all right
so thanks for teaching me how to edit
mares awesome awesome
they have purple sweetest hey you know
what I'm still I'm still watching us
dude because Jordan Jordan fields the
homie we got to support Jordan dude well
you should still see it I still I want
to see I'm probably gonna go see you
tomorrow dude I saw it get out like
Steve accept the invite yes send another
one send another one it's right here so
you're eating purple swedish fish never
had that um yes swedish um these are
swedish yeah fish mini ones are purple
there's purple orange what other colors
are there white orange pink purple
interesting yeah
break up you want to do the Ouija board
you want to do the witty way
you'll do it let's clear this now I'll
do I'll on it would be so mad babe
[Music]
call it Drake Oh what if he writes
darling and just remember Steve we're
streaming yeah I know I'm not saying no
cuz a fan um gave me a Ouija board and
now it's over at Craigs and I'm we're
we're contemplating whether we should do
the Ouija damn I wish I was there doing
it you want to block the Ouija board
dude if it if you if it there's a ghost
in here how scared would you be it's one
of the skeletons and your body are knows
it's a skeleton it's one of those dead
skeletons in the back yeah oh my god
Oh call him
dude is this review is that a new [ __ ]
dude I'm so out of touch I have no idea
we may take it oh dude it's too in them
it's 2:30 in the morning no I didn't I
got up at like noon today
what about taking you want you to play
me in Tekken yeah you said something
about Tekken you know what I'm gonna
relax how you were left on the couch I'm
gonna lay back chill
what map is this dude well map I don't
remember the name to be honest like
literally Steve I just got back into
playing destiny Oh what other playing
managerial monk FIFA so it's like I've
just been like geeking out on that nice
you know honestly we were just been
playing this and then apex legends a
nasty can you are can you ask Craig if
he played the new samurai game that came
out you play the new samurai game that
came up worked here huh
hell yeah and we might be doing a raid
soon Steve we need you dude there's a
new way
oh nice you got on the same
look two-for-one baby oh no not anymore
oh my god you know what it's slowly
starting to come back to me alright
you know this guy she's [ __ ]
who which guy dude they're chatting dude
don't that's inappropriate dude I'm not
gonna ask of that no I'm not gonna ask
you that no I'm not gonna ask him that
what is Craig saying you said if you
still get your nuts
you're not touched no not any more
people that will fight John Byrne
section awesome
allegedly yeah
oh dude I fell off the map
what is that [ __ ] Craig I know all
right Craig yeah that's horrible
that's bad timing yeah no I don't think
he wants to talk about
thank you Steve yes
Craig you know at least I got one or two
kills so I'll do that bad
yeah but those are golden God lunch it's
the basics well I'm using I got rush
oh my god
you know what I need to get out of this
little nook right here go all the way
around
oh this guy's trying to sneak around huh
I told Steve about my nuts [ __ ] you
Craig why are you in the chat [ __ ] you
people and my work were allegedly
touched by guns Steve and that's it
[ __ ] Craig oh no I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry
really I freaking hate you crash
oh thank you thanks
okay
Gregg I'm sorry I'm ruining your KD dude
this is a close game we couldn't win
Steve well why don't even though I
haven't seen you the whole time there's
a god I'm going on camera
although these dark
five in a row hell yeah
oh man so sorry Craig it's hard to plan
your TV because I can't believe it's cuz
there's like a little ant can't really
yeah there's like the old times
come on man it's awesome having you here
yeah just kind of it going through yeah
I know I know keep right here
I can't talk about here but you need oh
hey look at that
oh we're gonna go up places awkward I'm
chillin
okay he thought without doing
we made a single
know why I have a I have a little race
phone that I did after shot that Frank -
Frank episode [ __ ] if you got a super
use it
[ __ ] it's closed 77275
these guys are running
let's go let's go let's go
nice credit Steve yeah we won I love you
Steve yeah little positive 1.46 nice all
right guys that's gonna be the end of
the stream thanks for tuning in check
out Steve's patreon check out our
patreon whoo everyone have a good night